I'm standing on the southern tip of
Africa and imagining what it was like
sometime in the last hundreds of
thousands of years back then Africa was
home to all the world's homo sapiens
all 10,000 of them if you were an
extraterrestrial on a survey mission you
might have thought we were an endangered
species
someday soon there will be 10 billion of
us what happened how did we become the
globe-girdling space traveling species
that we are today
welcome to the first laboratory on earth
where in blombo's cave with the
evolution of the mind made a great leap
our ancestors were conducting chemistry
experiments here with a mineral rich in
iron ochre they used it to decorate
objects with bits of red color but it
may have also had other uses to preserve
animal hives or as a medicine or as a
way to sharpen their tools or maybe it's
an insect repellent and they engraved
the ochre with symbols something
completely new on the planet Earth
alright not to be beaten not to provide
shelter but to symbolize something or
just to be looks a little bit like a
ladder or double helix whatever it was
supposed to be it's the earliest remnant
we have of human culture we had found a
way to leave behind something distinctly
human a means to communicate
however enigmatically to you and me 100
thousand years away the great power was
discovered here in one most cave
[Music]
you